What's up guys, Michael, here to talk about.
That's right.
Rugrats would have Nickelodeon's most beloved 90 shows ensure the antics of
Tommy and the gang are endearing, but when it comes to overthinking a kid show,
one thing really stood out to us,
their parents that's because if we do the very complicated arithmetic,
these nineties parents are the embodiment of the Internet's favorite object of
ridicule boomers. What's more they're boomers raising millennial children,
even if the little tykes weren't called that yet.
And once you start to think about the show from that perspective,
a certain shift in meaning occurs,
because what if we can understand a generation of people obsessed with anxiety
means and what Harry Potter house they belong to through this story of their
parents.
Let us explain in this wisecrack edition on rug rats and the rise of boomer
parents, and now for the briefest of recaps rug, rats, as you know, spotlights,
a playgroup of babies and toddlers, the core original group consists of Tommy,
the idealistic leader, Chucky, the perpetual worrywart,
Phil and Lil the warm love and sweeties and Angelica, the bratty bully.
When their parents leave the room, their imaginations go wild,
leading them on many fanciful,
occasionally horrifying adventures for context Rugrats debuted in
1991.
And while the eighties and nineties are often remembered as a time of relative
prosperity,
it also was a time of widening economic inequality and a rapidly shrinking
middle-class. As a result,
many baby boomers entered full on adulthood slash Parenthood and a state of very
real economic anxiety. They were faced with demanding mortgage payments,
stagnating wages, and a known Raveling social safety net,
which to be fair all still are things today.
These anxieties manifest in the pickles,
particularly in the early seasons D constantly worries about money saying things
like.
I think going over our bills still.
And I thought maybe if you've got a job outside the house.
Grocery shop to the calculator to avoid an unexpectedly high tech.
And don't forget the calculator pop and we're on a budget. Remember here.
DD reflects the reality of being a boomer during this era,
a reality described by journalists and Helen Peterson's book.
Can't even how millennials became the burnout generation.
Peterson looks at the plight of the stressed out millennials starting with the
trajectory of their boomer parents born between 1946 and 1964.
Baby boomers entered the world during the relative prosperity of the post-war
economic boom.
America had a robust social safety net and middle-class workers could generally
rely on the supportive labor unions for those greatest generation parents,
even a blue collar union job promised to middle-class Gloria,
along with the ability to buy a house and provide for your family,
including your crying boomer, baby, a scholar, Louis Hyman,
put it capitalism worked for nearly everyone,
but over the course of the next several decades,
the rise of what political scientist,
Jacob hacker calls the personal responsibility per se,
remolded American culture into one where increasingly people were left on their
own to succeed or fail without the help GI bills,
generous social security checks or a good union job.
As a result of boomers became a grownups in increasingly uncertain economic
times when maintaining a middle-class lifestyle is becoming harder and harder.
And for some people that worked out really, really well,
especially if you had no moral qualms about selling junk stocks on wall street,
greed is.
Right. Greed works.
And for everyone else, it was a huge bummer.
One that Rugrats may have accidentally documented in cartoon form. For example,
Tommy's,
dad's stew faces the constant pressure of operating a small business in a
ruthless economy.
Still, honey, I'm worried about you. I think you've been working too hard on it.
The pressure stoop faces manifests physically fill sleepwalk or be caught
talking to himself in a state of over exhaustion. And one episode,
Tommy fancifully wonders.
If his dad is secretly a robot and Stu stress do sleepwalking confirms his
fears here,
we see Tommy accurately perceiving the way economic anxiety weighs on his
father. At another point, Chuckie, similarly relays, his father's own concerns.
My daddy Sadie's afraid the bosses coulda fire here.
So what happened is baby boomers adjusted to a new,
more cutthroat normal as Peterson describes it, the generation of weed, token,
hippie protesters evolve from being more socially minded agitators to becoming
increasingly insular or as economist Mathias, dukkha,
and for breezy Mozilla body put it. They decided to look out for themselves.
They invested more in their education and individual success while deaning
social protection, less important.
Anyone who seen rug rats could perceive this cutthroat mentality and the
character of Angelica's mom, Charlotte,
the incessantly cell phone chatting business woman and CEO of the very ominous
sounding Megacorp. Charlotte's known for saying things like.
The junk bond market is coming back. And I,
for one intend to be in a position to take advantage of the tool.
Her selfishness while played for laughs actually just exaggerates a very real
social and cultural shift that took place in the hearts and minds of many non
cartoon boomers. Long before you were telling me.
Old lady suck, okay.
Now his boomers became increasingly focused on the self and keeping that self
economically, socially and physically successful.
They were vying to maintain middle-class steps.
This new mentality resulted in the rise of the yuppie.
That is the special brand of college educated boomer,
who according to Peterson can basically be defined by their lavish consumption
habits, their gadgets, or vacations or French sparkling wine. Also preludes.
According to Peterson,
the yuppie mentality took form over the course of the seventies,
metastasized in the eighties and became the base temperature of the nineties and
make no mistake.
The rug rats parents may be some of the happiest yuppies ever to yuppie as the
LA times noted in a 1998 review of the show,
particularly in early seasons of the parents are hyper concerned with projecting
prosperity.
Pop-up show for one year. Why not a little France?
Aren't even gonna remember it. They'll remember this one,
pop rated number one by birthdays magazine.
And besides do we want to be remembered the family that settled.
For less, they are.
Super consumption, happy lusting after boats and fancy golf clubs,
they filmed their banal vacations on their camcorder.
There's there's D packing for our vacation to the grand Canyon
and obsess over healthy.
Don't order. The many junk food or out take your time.
They take their hobbies seriously and present their new neighbors with
decorative jello molds and throw nightmare inducing, costume parties galore.
Occasionally they even rent a limo buses to show off for their friends.
We even rented a limo bus to celebrate Steve's.
Big night. Of course, there are moments of reprieve from their yuckiness,
the dueling realities of the boomer identity between flower child and sharper
image. Loving yuppie comes to a head in the second season.
When the pickles throw a garage sale to reduce bloated clutter of commodities.
You got your five Jews, Sacha [inaudible] lamb from that old standby,
the pet rock, the chiller.
We'll drink trying to be helpful.
Move all the beloved belongings that the parents chose not to sell outside.
And the family ends up accidentally pawning off everything they own.
After a brief moment of panic upon seeing their empty house,
the pickles go full circle almost as if retreating to the antique consumption
ideals of the sixties, at least temporarily. I mean,
all we lost for material possessions.
And what we've rediscovered are the important.
Things like family and.
And other human values, hell they eat.
And sing [inaudible].
But for the most part, they stay in character, put a sock in at the.
What else did boomer yuppies do? According to Peterson,
surrounded by perceived threats and growing uncertainty.
Middle-class boomers doubled down on what they could try to control their
children.
And indeed nothing made boomers more crazy than the pressure to be good parents
and provide well for their spawn.
Early on the show sets this tone pretty clearly as DD panics over throwing the
perfect first birthday party for Tommy complete with a puppet show that no one
year old deserves.
My future as a mother, depends on this party.
And the party depends on the public.
Contrast.
Her approach with Tommy's greatest generation grandpa who was raised in became a
parent than a more hands-off age.
Why when I was a spot, we didn't have puppet shells and we wanted entertainment.
We went out back and pulled up stops after.
The puppet show fails, DD frats that.
I never live up to being the kind of mother I want to be. You know,
like those moms on TV here.
D reflects the nearly omnipresent desire among boomers to be a model parent,
and to perform that good Parenthood for the whole neighborhood.
She like many millennial parents who would come after her internalized a stress
inducing message that as sociologist Sharon Hayes put it,
the methods of appropriate child rearing are construed as child centered expert
guidance, emotionally absorbing labor intensive and financially expensive.
This pressure is encapsulated by DDS realization.
A few seasons later that she had abandoned her work on deals, baby book,
forever losing the chance to memorialize the first time he burped or pooped
pants, better.
Baby book, and write that down. Woo.
Again, she feels like she's failed at the same time.
Boomers worried about their child raising methods.
They became fixated on what sociologists and that Lareau calls concerted
cultivation.
That is the process of carefully developing their children via cello lessons,
expensive summer camps, and ensuring that they're trilingual by the age of 10.
But given the persistent economic anxiety that permeated the era,
these choices start to make more sense.
It was all in the pursuit of their desire to raise children who had maintained
their middle-class status. If they failed,
they feared their kids would grow up to be the lowly garbage collector who keeps
our neighborhoods clean rather than getting paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars to do whatever the consultant does as Peterson puts it,
the child's wellbeing and more importantly,
their future capacity for success is paramount.
Deedee can barely get through a sentence without referring to her favorite child
expert. She obsesses over the minutia of how she rears Tommy.
Diapers. Wipeys books, blankets, a cap,
a change of clothes band-aids in case of emergency and two extra bottles of
cheese.
And takes him to maximum security daycare.
The parents panic over bottle-feeding.
So this boy that his parents didn't think it was important to wean him this
child. Well, you get my point.
They panic over running noses. I've tried.
Everything. Decongestants, herbal remedies, Chad D and boy.
Boy, do they panic over potty training with Chucky's dad, even Freddie. Now.
He's going to be taken diapers to work with limit his briefcase.
Here at Chaz is literally worrying about how his failure to potty train Chucky
in a timely manner could be a threat to the mini Ginger's career.
And therefore middle-class status.
The boomer need to carefully cultivate their child is best exemplified.
In an episode of when Angelica takes up painting for a very yuppy reason.
My personal shaman said it was absolutely the best way to nurture her creative
side.
Immediately. Her mother praises her work saying.
I love it. The total abandonment of form,
the disregard of balance it's so Jackson.
Little does she know that this, um,
abstract expressionism is actually the result of the baby's fooling around with
paint. That's a nice touch, which maintains the rug. Rats,
Maxim that the best things happen when kids are just allowed to be kids it's
worth noting that concerted cultivation also makes a prominent appearance and it
rug rats all grown up episode. When the kids panic over a fifth grade,
standardized test.
Depends on his chest.
Meanwhile, Angelica's mom urges her to start worrying about her college resume,
giving her 11 year old daughter, totally normal advice. Like you.
Must do things that'll impress the college admissions office show concern for
the environment, your fellow male.
Well, the grand result of concerted cultivation was as Peterson puts it,
that boomers raised in many adults,
millennials who quickly grew up and began mimicking the habits of adulthood,
cue excessive anxiety, fittingly the rug.
Rats are mini adults in a lot of ways, worried about living up to expectations.
Well then go play in the sandbox. I care Chucky on my daddy went away.
And once we had to be the man of the home.
And worried like their parents about their own child develop, we.
Ain't going to be a big baby. Anyway, also.
Fittingly they're prone to suffering from real bouts of anxiety.
Sometimes sounding like they have the weight of the world on their shoulders.
Life is so hard. Copy.
Angelica for one becomes an expert at performing her parents' expectations of a
perfect childhood.
What difference does it make?
Who did what the impressing is that we're all here and we love each
other after all family is really what matters. Right?
Of course,
she simultaneously develops a low key diabolical alter ego that allows her to
vent her pent up anger and frustration in the playpen. At the same time,
she seems to innately have picked up her mother's love of luxurious consumption,
a hankering best displayed when she harasses a mall Santa until he quits his
job. So were the Rugrats always doomed to grow into the anxious, depressed,
burned out millennials that Peterson analyzes in her book, maybe,
but we wonder if their fate was really set in stone. And for one main reason,
the same reason that makes rug rats. So fun to watch. Unlike a lot of boomers,
the Rugrats folks are way too self-absorbed to be true helicopter parents.
That is to say their patented parenting move is to put the kids in the playpen
and F the hell off. This was perhaps out of narrative necessity,
a show about babies sitting on their parents' laps,
listening to classical music while learning to read at age two and a half is a
lot less fun than a show about kids. We can have it.
We'll imagine themselves in outer space as a result of the rug,
rats get plenty of time to themselves,
away from their parents to Rosie's and paranoia's time to play, time to dream.
And that's something a lot of middle-class millennial kids didn't get much of
Peterson notes that working class millennial children whose working parents
didn't have the luxury videotaping.
Their every burp often had a lot more free reign.
That meant more of what she calls natural growth or the conscious or unconscious
allotment of unstructured time, which allows children to cultivate curiosity,
independence, and learn to negotiate peer dynamics on their own inadvertently,
perhaps,
and despite their very real anxiety and neuroses about raising their children,
right? The regret's parents give them a lot of this unstructured time to do the
important things like imagine themselves as pirates. This kind of play.
According to Peterson,
helps kids develop independence and a strong sense of self.
It also makes for good television. At the end of the day,
Rugrats is fascinating for its depiction of boomer parenting while also
strategically leaving out one,
all important tactic of boomer parents as Peterson puts it constant surveillance
and protected childhood.
We think that may be part of the broad appeal of the show at a time when kids
increasingly had less licensed to goof around watching kids go on adventures,
reminiscent of a different era was extraordinarily appealing.
Perhaps there was some catharsis we might not have been allowed to play outside
and supervised,
but we got to watch the Rugrats build their own Noah's Ark in complete freedom.
But what do you guys think are the rads parents,
exemplary boomer parents with these lumpy babies have grown up to be depressed,
millennials, meaning their way through our current.
Hellscape let us know in the comments,
a huge thanks to our current patrons for supporting the channel and say hello to
our new ones. Check us out at patrion.com/wisecrack for ad-free videos and more.
And before you go, don't forget to pet that subscribe button,
real song like it's the head of your overprotected five-year-old self.
And as always, thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].